everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we are covering
game 6
from the match of the century 1972 World
Chess Championship between Bobby Fischer
and buddy Spassky in game 5 Bobby
Fischer battled back to even up the
series so coming into game 6 Bobby
Fischer has the white pieces and he has
leveled the playing field now he has
hinted to his team each player has a
team behind them kind of your main point
person is called your second but they do
have a couple people that they prepare
for different lines different variations
in those particular openings Bobby
Fischer kind of hinted that I was going
to play something different in game 6
now that kind of leaked out in birdies
spassky's team had kind of even
mentioned hey what if we see something
different besides the common pawn to e4
which Bobby Fischer he loved before
played it more than anything else
sometimes even talked bad about other
openings he just didn't play much of
anything else but he's fast he said you
know no big deal I'm kind of prepared
for it I play all these other openings
and Bobby Fischer do exactly that I
started out with pawn to c4 we'd really
only seen Bobby Fischer play this
particular opening twice ever in
competitive play so pretty interesting
from him and such a high competitive
stage to come out play something he's
not as familiar with pawn to c4 met with
pawn to e6 and then Knight f3 pawn at d5
transposing into the Queens gambit
declined line with pawn to d4 and Bobby
Fischer had been pretty adamant about
the Queens gambit not being a
particularly good line and he had never
played this in competitive play so it's
pretty interesting that he chose this
even after the c4 to transpose it to the
Queens gambit declined line but you can
pretty much bet that he had something in
store for birdie Spassky if you wanted
to go and play this Knight f6 then
Knight c3 Bishop e7 at Bishop g5 to get
the Bishop outside the pawn chain before
pawn to e3 and then castle on the Kings
side and then pawn to e3
but he's Spassky decided to play the
types of Cour defense which is a
particularly with pawn to h6 and after
Bishop back here h4 pawn to b6 and he's
very familiar with this line he's
never lost this line in competitive play
coming into the game so we felt
confident playing this so you have one
side of the board that's not really
played this line in competitive play
against one of the top players in the
world the world champion at the moment
that has played this to perfection his
entire career so going to be pretty
interesting we do see some sacrifices
starts here on d5 the bishop takes here
on e7 Queen takes Knight takes and the
pond recaptures here and then work swing
over here to c1 just attacking
controlling this semi open file here on
the C file a bishop here to e6 and white
has a few options here we could seed
Knight to e5 we could see Bishop to d3
getting ready to castle on the King side
we could even see more of a quiet move
from Bobby Fischer pawn to h3 he decides
to go for a more aggressive route which
makes me believe which makes total sense
is he definitely prepared for this on it
plays Queen to a4 and this is not a move
that you typically make against someone
that knows the defense very well unless
you have a very particular game plan
going forward and you can tell that he
does as this game continues a pawn to c5
and then the Queen back here to a3 just
putting pressure on this c5 square Rick
over here c8 a Bishop b5 and then pawn
to a6 and this is pretty interesting the
second for birdie Spassky was a fellow
named Geller and in 1978 so just a
couple years ago he played this exact
same line and he played Queen to b7 and
had great success with it and so I'm not
really sure if you know Geller didn't go
over this particular line I would
imagine he would or if for some reason
but a Spassky forgot about it or just
decided to maybe improve on it a little
bit but decide to play pawn to a6 I
think Queen to b7 is definitely worthy
to take a look at but after pawn to a6
we see the pawn take here on c5 and the
pawn recapture what's nice is this
bishops kind of hanging out here but the
pawn can't take you yet because then the
Queen's just going to sweep up here
- a8 and take that rook right here so
it's just kind of toying with his
opponent having this bishop here on b5
now the castle on the Kings side a rook
to a7 if you kind of ask me what I would
do just because I don't like Bobby
Fischer having so much pressure on my
side I would play Knight to c6
developing the state of the board if he
wants to take that's fine I can
recapture with my rook right here but
kind of blocks off some of what the the
white Bishop here is doing also opens up
the door I can take with my pawn here
and then I have a defense with my rook
here on c8 but decides to play rook here
to eat a seven this does allow him to
take with his pawn right now since the
Queen would be able to protect this rook
so Bobby Fischer decides to go and bring
his Bishop back here to e2 and then
Knight to d7 does need to activate it is
not involved into the game yet so d7 is
the first spot Bobby Fischer continues
with Knight to d4 seems like another one
of those moves where he's somewhat
toying with his opponent saying you wish
you could take my minor piece with your
pawn but you can't because then I would
just sweep up here and take your rook
here on c8 normal people like myself I
think you're just going to be playing
rook here to d1 I think it makes a lot
of sense I think it's a strong move from
Bobby Fischer control discern the board
these two semi open files with his rooks
that's going to be very good all of his
other pieces are fairly active but
decides to go and play Knight here to d4
potentially just mess with his opponent
but it is a very strong central square
decides to go ahead and take the bishop
off the board after the pawn recaptures
he now has a bishop and his opponent has
a knight so he's going to try to limit
all the squares that the knight can go
to and really control the board with his
Bishop that's currently on e to first
he's gonna start out with pawn to e4 and
this is a tricky spot for black because
he would like to just take it right away
but he's going to have two isolated
pawns right here that Bobby Fischer can
attack the rest of the game but if he
doesn't take it gets pretty tricky as
far as how he really plays with this
pawn structure in the stern of the board
I'll kind of show you that because he
played pawn to d4 he just didn't like
taking it he wants to live I spawn chain
a little bit more but pawn to f4 first
making it very difficult for pawn to e5
which buddies fast II may want to play
first we see Queen to e7 but then pawn
to e5 is very difficult there is now a
backward isolated pawn here on e6 it's
no longer connected to these pawns right
here and it kind of blocks off a lot of
the action for birdie Spassky to bring
his pieces over to the King side and now
Bobby Fischer is going to be aiming a
lot of his pieces at this weekend King
side and see if he can have a very very
strong attack rook here b8 attacking the
pawn here on a b2 bishop up here to c4
starting to add pressure on this
backward pawn isolated pawn here on e6
King here to h8 wants to make sure that
it's not this pawns not being pinned
down and for some reason the Queen moves
I just don't want to have any attack
right there so Queen here to h8 then
Quinn over here to h3 so if you kind of
look at this board you can see Bobby
Fischer's starting to really build an
attack on the King side it's going to be
up to but he's basky to find a way to
defend against this his knight right
here is pretty much obsolete it can't
come here to e5 can't come here to f6
she's just going to fall on board can't
come here to b8 that's not doing
anything b6 is going the opposite
direction he needs to be on the King
side f8 s probably his only invest move
but even there it's not doing too much
just playing defense on the square and E
six but that just doesn't feel all that
good but is you kind of look at there's
just not much else for him to do so he
plays Knight to f8 if he looks at and
says okay let me take here with rook to
b2 then all of a sudden the bishop takes
here on e6
that's not very good you can start to
see things crumble the pawns can start
to push forward this is going to be very
tough for buddy's fast key to hold on to
maybe rook here to the b7 now but that
still doesn't feel all that good so in
the game he decides to go ahead and play
Queen here h3 and then Knight back here
to f8 Bobby Fischer continues with pawn
to d3 just solidifying his pawn chain a
little bit on the Queen side doesn't
have to worry about the rook coming in
getting involved on the Queen side of
the board also allows just for this
outpost here for the
this bishops not going anywhere it's
controlling a lot of the sin of the
board which is nice
upon here to a5 starting to attack on
the queenside try to break up the side
of the board with his rook as protection
but it's just too little too late Bobby
Fischer just goes for the jugular here
he realizes his opponent is on the ropes
and he just pushes forward with all of
his power
starting with pawn to f5 and this is
just a strong attack after the pawn
takes the rooks going to recapture here
a knight here to h7 but this this nice
just going to be stuck for the rest of
the game it just can't do too much then
rook over here f1 just lining up all the
pieces Queen here to d8 if we were to
see something you know pawn to a4 then
all of a sudden Queen here to g3 we
could see a capture here but rook up
here to f7 it gets very difficult as far
as you know how blacks actually going to
come out of this Queen verse between and
Bishop verse Knights and rook definitely
not going to go well Queen to d8 make
some sense trying to just protect both
sides of the board but it's just very
difficult right now to protect
everything a Queen g3 Rick here to e7
starting to attack this pawn here on e5
but Bobby Fischer
he says okay that's that's fine I have
two pieces defending that right now so
I'm starting to push forward with h4
this does limit some of the moves that
black has can't come here to g5 anymore
with his knight so just slowly over time
putting more and more pressure on his
opponent paneer to a e6 it is being
protected by the bishop so that's a nice
little square rook here to c7 Queen e5
Queenie AIT's a for pushing it does have
some other options doesn't have to play
a four but decides wants to go and just
see what his opponent's going to be
doing he can easily easily just continue
to put pressure but a4 doesn't even have
to worry about black playing a4 at any
given time Queen to d8 a rook up here to
f2 could have easily come to f4 even if
you wanted to just moving around a
little bit
Queenie eight
rook up to f3 Queen to d8 just kind of
waiting for his opponent to make a
mistake but there's just no good moves
that he has so Bishop to d3
Queenie 8 and then after Queen to e4 but
he's fast he can probably just resigned
there's just too much pressure going on
there's no way for him to really stop
anything decides to play Knight to f6 he
can't really take with rook on a 6 if we
continue with here rook up here f8 check
the knight takes the rook takes the
Queen takes and then all of a sudden
it's checkmate there's no way to stop
that mating pattern so we see Knight f6
but then the rook takes after the pawn
takes the rook takes here on f6 King
here g8 Bishop c4 came back here h8 and
then Queen to f4 on this particular spot
but e Spassky resign now a lot of times
people say you know why did he resign
well if it's not super obvious which it
may not be that's fine we could see a
continuation is a forced mating pattern
but let's say King to g8 if we wanted to
a recover here taking let's say the rook
takes Queen up here f6 getting ready for
mate with rook here on h8 so trying to
stop that Bishop takes here on e6 Queen
takes Queen is going to recapture and
then all of a sudden we do see a mate
shortly after that and we could have a
few variations of that but all in all
there is no way after Queen to f4 from
stopping this it is a mate and I think
it was around 11 depending on how long
buddy Spassky wanted to play it out so
afterwards Bobby Fischer got an ovation
from the audience and Betty Spassky
actually clapped form as well gave him
applause and said this was an
exceptional performance not really
playing the Queen's game at the climb
line and coming out and playing it
perfectly as for what Spassky said and
he knew this defense very well and he
said he just lost to a better player so
Bobby Fischer kind of showing the world
that he could play with the best with
their specialty and he could still beat
them and so he does take a game
advantage going into game number seven
Bobby Fischer played extremely good game
probably the best game we've seen in the
series so far he's really starting to be
a little bit more aggressive even in his
games so thank you guys for watching
hopefully you enjoyed this video and the
series so well and I'll see you guys the
next one for Game seven